welcome my name is Natalie Kent and I'm
a sophomore here studying English and
French I'm here this evening to
introduce our new speaker dr. mark blitz
mark blitz is the Fletcher Jones
professor of political philosophy at
Claremont McKenna College he earned his
a B and PhD from Harvard University
prior to his appointment at Claremont
McKenna
he taught political philosophy at
Harvard University and the University of
Pennsylvania he served during in direct
the Reagan administration as associate
director of the United States
Information Agency where he was the
senior United States official in charge
of educational and cultural programs
abroad
dr. blitz has also served as a senior
staff member of the Senate Committee on
Foreign Relations and as vice president
of the Hudson Institute he's the author
of numerous books titled conserving
Liberty Plato's political philosophy
duty-bound responsibility and American
public life and he Gators being and time
and the possibility of political
philosophy ladies and gentlemen please
welcome dr. Mark Bloods
[Applause]
thanks Natalie for that nice
introduction I once worked in government
for someone very controversial and
whenever he gave a speech and received a
nice introduction he would look around
and say I must be in the wrong room but
I'm in the right room and thank you all
for being here I don't pretend to be an
expert on Confucius although I've taught
his Analects but it's not completely
unreasonable that I'm talking to you
about him my area academically is
political philosophy
specifically Plato and Aristotle but
also 19th and 20th century German
philosophy and it turns out that
Aristotle and Plato are very good
jumping-off points for us in order to
understand and consider Confucius as
Natalie mentioned I was also at one
point this was during Ronald Reagan's
second term in charge of our country's
academic and young leader exchange
programs the Fulbright Program and other
programs similar to that and also of our
books and libraries and foreign cultural
centers kind of the u.s. equivalent of
what China now has with its abroad with
all of its Confucius centers these
centers which they've started in various
universities to some degree for
propagandistic purposes to some degree
to keep tabs on students but in general
we didn't do any such things the point
of our u.s. programs was what was then
called mutual understanding now they
call it soft power we actually thought
of it during the Reagan administration
as
the war of ideas the war of ideas
freedom capitalism liberal democracy on
one side communism on the other side so
I was as it were an officer in this war
and therefore have considered something
about the effect of fought on a people
as a whole
something relevant obviously to
Confucius and China obviously in a way
the war of ideas never ends as we see
today even if one prevails for a while
as we did but it's a continuing and
ongoing effort so Confucius were more
literally master Cong wonderful name
lived they think because these things
are always a bit hazy or a year or two
lived let's say from 5th from 551 to 479
BC his family was nobility but he was
himself not wealthy and he always
referred favorably to the Jo dynasty
which ruled his home state which was in
northern China this rule was breaking
down during his life he had various
minor political positions never really a
major one although it seems that he and
his students wanted major positions that
was one of his goals not achieved and
for long periods of time he was just an
itinerant teacher the facts of his life
are hazy because reports of them are not
really contemporaneous they occur much
later most important for us the status
of the Analects which is
the central compilation of his views the
status of the Analects as a text as we
scholars say is very unclear the present
text was compiled by a much later Scala
scholar which sayings were written or
said by him or were compiled from things
he actually said who knows for sure so
it would be very hard to study the
Analects with a kind of precision with
which one would study a novel or even
one of the works of Plato where you can
be certain that the author wrote the
thing and you can study the work as if
it reflects the intention of the author
unclear when you study Confucius that
you can do something like that
so scholars try to resolve these
uncertainties by considering what was
handed down after his death and then
dismissing what seems historically
anachronistic the Analects are composed
of twenty books a bunch of what are
called chapters in each book but the
chapters are just these short sayings by
and large books three through nine and
eleven through fifteen of the twenty are
generally considered to be authentic and
books four through eight are thought to
be the oldest but these I think are
thoughts and no one knows certainly
so this uncertainty as I said really
affects the precision with which anyone
can study him now Confucius is
significant first because his thought or
his statements and those of his
disciples have become so important in
China and in the countries influenced by
it and second of course he's significant
because of the content of the thought
itself
his work went through various stages of
influence it became significant
especially during the dynasty which
began to rule China in 960 this was when
the civil service examinations that were
based on Confucius really took hold this
importance of Confucius and commentaries
on Confucius for the civil service
examinations which helped to rise to the
top this went on until 1905
so Confucius's great influence comes
first from the fact that in order to
make your career and keep your way you
had to know him for the exams and second
because much of that seeped down much of
what he said then seeped down to
ordinary views so even when Mata Tong
attacked Confucius and Confucian
thinking which he did this didn't really
I think take hold because of the
historic influence and power of the fog
you might think here to a much lesser
extent but nonetheless of the brittle of
the British civil service in its heyday
let's say from the last half or last
third of the 19th century until the Cold
War when everyone pretty much who went
to the schools from which senior people
were drawn knew the Greek and Latin
classics and some knew them very well or
you might consider the upper crust of
the French civil service where they all
study and they still studied Descartes
and the Enlightenment and so on and the
upper crusts of these civil services are
extremely important in running the
country
Confucius expresses the point of this
kind of education rather than a merely
technical education in one of his
remarks
let me read it the master said would it
be wonderful to have before anything you
said the master said the master said a
gentleman does not behave as a tool the
education is not merely an education to
be an implement or a tool for someone
else but it's to be the kind of
education to lead in govern so I
mentioned at the beginning the likeness
that people sometimes see to Aristotle
and why Plato and Aristotle or a good
jumping-off point for understanding
Confucius and I'll begin my discussion
of the substance of the ad elects by
saying what compared to Aristotle it is
not what's the difference and I think
that'll help us to place the Analects
intellectually or philosophically in
relation to something more familiar
compared to Aristotle there's no
development of practical reason there's
no development of the elements of
practical reasoning nor is there a
defense of intellectual reason or what
Aristotle calls intellectual virtue as
such there's no defense of unbridled
philosophical inquiry of the sort one
sees in book 10 of Aristotle's ethics or
in Plato and in the Republic in
particular compared to Aristotle there's
also no systematic discussion of the
elements of justice or the elements of
happiness or of the virtues or even
friendship there's lots of discussion of
some of those things but no systematic
discussion by that I mean not only that
matters aren't traced to some
ontological or metaphysical foundation
they're not but they're not really an
Aristotle either
in the ethics I mean that but I also
mean that the varieties and alternatives
of virtue justice happiness are not
systematically traced and categorized as
Aristotle does compared to Aristotle
there's also no discussion really of the
human soul and the powers and abilities
of the human soul even Aristotle's
elementary discussion in the ethics let
alone Plato's discussion of the powers
of the soul in the Republic or both of
their more fundamental discussions in
other works compared to John Locke in a
way the one of the great intellectual
founders behind the Declaration of
Independence compared to John Locke
there are in Confucius no individual
rights
no individual natural rights no tracing
of political authority to natural
individual authority no opening up a
property to full private acquisition and
no true consent of the governed there's
little valuing of competition the master
said there's nothing which gentlemen
compete over if competition were
inevitable it would be an archery
wouldn't it but they go up bowing and
making way for each other and when they
come down they have a drink so even in
their competition with each other they
are gentlemen no real competition argued
for is a good thing in a manner similar
to ours in terms of what Confucius does
emphasized in these books but is not
discussed in Aristotle one obvious
difference is Confucius's emphasis on
ritual on custom on forms of dress on
manners one might say there's nothing at
all
all in the ethics of Aristotle or in his
other works that's really like book ten
of the Analects of Confucius which is
where a lot of this discussion of ritual
occurs so because of all of these facts
the discussions in Confucius or the
sayings in Confucius often seem more
like exhorting hortatory statements of
the fine of the sort that you might
occasionally even find in in elements of
Plato's dialogues before then Plato and
Socrates dig into the real meaning and
intellectual substance of those issues
the Analects are really about how to
follow away how to follow a traditional
way in terms of what he thinks is best
in that way and given whatever choices
are still open to it
all of that said lots of what he
recommends that you do or I think what
we would also recommend to fully explore
the substance of the Analects would
require a lengthy study but I can at
least indicate I think the major terms
the major guidelines of Confucius is
thought I put it this way in terms of
guidelines because the Analects as I
just indicated are about how to behave
but in particular they're about how to
behave generally if you have or aspire
to a particular role or a particular
station they're not based on universal
individualism where everything is in
principle open to everyone they're not
really based on the kind of behavior
which is in principle open to everyone
but they're very much tied to particular
roles particular status in addition to
considering the Analects by thinking
about its major
guidelines one should also see that
Confucius's remarks are often directed
to particular disciples they're a group
of disciples with whom he has these
discussions in the Analects and they're
different there are particular qualities
particular limits that are mentioned in
the Analects itself
so it's not always clear if a given
remark is meant to be generally
applicable as it might seem or more
particularly applicable to whoever the
one to whom it's being addressed so give
it all this what are the major terms or
major thoughts there's first the key
human type the key or central human type
that he recommends the gentleman as
opposed to the petty or small man that's
the difference to read a couple of
things
ji Kang Zi asked master Kong about
government saying suppose I were to kill
those who lack the way in order to
advance those who have the way how would
that be master Kong replied you are
running the government so what is the
point of killing if you desire good the
people will be good the nature of the
gentleman is as the wind and the nature
of the small man is as the grass when
the wind blows over the grass
it always bends so this is among of
course his famous sayings on which you
could reflect for a long time to read
something else about about gentlemen
which he says the master said the
gentleman reaches out for what is above
the small man reaches out for what is
below you'd rather be a gentleman of
course there are also people he calls
men of quality those who have particular
virtues particular skills those he calls
sages who have a certain level of
learning even beyond the gentleman
there's further what he once calls the
complete man all of these are high or
desirable types and it's the gentleman
whose most fully described he also
discusses the people who are governed
various levels of government officials
there's very little on women by the way
and the major statement about women
would be politically incorrect for us
now
hi there I therefore won't read it to
you now gentlemen are supposed to embody
or exemplify a characteristic which you
can transyl it's called ran NAR en when
it's transliterated and so on that's the
central quality it's often translated as
umaña's or humanity sometimes translated
as generosity benevolence might be
better or perhaps kind of graciousness
propriety refinement you might say it's
the gracious ease or propriety that in
the past used to define the gentleman
not just his past but our past as well
you might call this graciousness or
humane this the broad substance of
virtuous action in regard to others one
reason that graciousness or benevolence
in a way as a useful translation may be
more than humane this simply is because
this quality is not something I think
characteristic of all human beings as
Confucius sees it again it's most likely
the graceful ease and propriety of the
gentleman in particular to be humane
I'll use that term is not to be rude or
course or devious the master said when
substance prevails over refinement
there's Trishna s' and when refinement
or mere refinement prevails over
substance there is pedantry only if
refinement and substance are properly
blended does one become a gentleman
now next point really the virtues or you
Maness or benevolence generally are
displayed primarily in various
relationships with parents
therefore familial piety or familial
duty which is another central practice
of course in Confucius and loyalty
generally master you said master used
one of the disciples few indeed are
those who are naturally filial towards
their parents and dutiful towards their
elder brothers but are also fond of
opposing their superiors and it never
happens it never happens that those who
do not like opposing their superiors are
fond of creating civil disorder it's the
kind of so-called conservatism of
Confucius the gentleman concerns himself
with the root and if the root is firmly
planted the way grows filial piety and
fraternal duty surely they are the roots
of you Maness the master said young men
should be filial when at home and
respectful to elder's went away from
home they should be earnest and
trustworthy although they should love
the multitude far and wide they should
be intimate only with the humane
I'll read one other
the Duke of she told master Kong in my
locality there's a certain paragon for
when his father stole a sheep he the son
bore witness against him master Kong
said in my locality those who are
upright are different from this father's
cover up for their sons and sons cover
up for their fathers uprightness is to
be found in this yeah
and that can be compared with a
well-known dialogue on piety of plato's
called the Euthyphro which whose action
concerns this kind of thing it's not
clear I think from all this that piety
towards one's father is meant to be as
complete morally or as oppressive as it
seems to have become in some later
periods in China in loyalty one also
displays other characteristics
friendliness honesty or trustworthiness
again gentlemanly or virtuous actions
are displayed and are connected to these
people and functions they're not merely
for Confucius a general set of qualities
that follow some sort of universal law
as I said Confucius does not trace the
virtues and the qualities to their
intellectual roots they are recommended
and to a disc to a degree they're
described but they're not really
defended philosophically now as I've
said and have just been saying the
favored human types let's say the
gentlemen the ones to which one aspires
even if you can't quite reach it the
gentlemen and the sage all of these
practise virtuous actions not abstractly
or
objects of universal rules but rather
they practice them always within a
context and the context and this is
really the next point the context is
primarily or directly within ritual
behavior or customary ritual li li is
the term that's usually translated in
one of those ways that's also connected
to reverence and courteous behavior but
it's not at least it seems not to be in
Confucius religious worship of gods or
direct concern with an afterlife where
Confucius is on that issue is a deep
question for those who study him ritual
behavior also reflects and involves
refined and cultured behavior so to sum
this up the central element of Confucius
is teaching what is central is
graciousness or propriety in customary
practices and customary relations that
really is the is kind of the central
substantive element of confuses set of
teachings to read again some of that
zhang Gong asked about you Maness the
master said when you are away from home
behave as if receiving an important
guest employ the people as if you were
officiating at a great sacrifice do not
impose on others what you would not like
yourself then there will be no
resentment against you either in the
state or in the family zhang gong said
although i'm not clever i beg to put
this advice into practice
fanch II another disciple asked about
you Maness the master said courtesy and
private life reverence in handling
business loyalty and relations with
others this should not be set aside even
if one visits the Barbarian tribes and a
final one in this group master kong said
there nine things
the gentleman concentrates on in seeing
he concentrates on clarity and listening
he concentrates on acuteness an
expression he concentrates on warmness
in demeanor he concentrates on courtesy
in words he concentrates on loyalty in
deeds he concentrates on reverence when
he's in doubt he concentrates on asking
questions when he's indignant he
concentrates on the problems kind of the
obstacles which would slow you down slow
down here in dignity and when he sees
opportunity for gain he concentrates on
what is right a heart group of things I
think to actually do so completely now
the next point all of this again let's
call the gentleman leanness and humane
this all this comes together only with
learning moral and cultural as well as
to a degree military and mathematical
learning the master said you have heard
the six sayings about the six hitting
hidden consequences when he replied that
he had not the master went on sit down
and I will tell you if one loves you
Maness but does not love learning the
consequence of this is folly if one
loves understanding but does not love
learning the consequence of this is
unorthodoxy if one loves good
faith but does not love learning the
consequence of this is damaging behavior
if one loves straightforwardness but
does not love learning the consequence
of this is rudeness if one loves courage
but does not love learning the
consequence of this is rebellious nassif
one loves strength but does not love
learning the consequence of this is
violence so people can of course deviate
from propriety they probably usually do
in fact and Confucius's interest his
concern is to restore us to what he
thinks is the proper way this proper way
he also indicates actually occurred
earlier in the reign of the the Duke
Zhuo the perfect or best time as
Confucius sees it is actually thought of
as something which once concretely
existed he doesn't project the kind of
impossible best government rather the
best government is something he claims
actually to have existed in the past
in fact Confucius thinks of himself as a
transmitter not as a creator the master
said I transmit but do not create being
fond of the truth I am an admirer of
antiquity the master said if by keeping
the old warm one can provide
understanding of the new one is fit to
be a teacher
that's a nice
nice thought as so many of these are so
one can see in all of this that he
exhorts us to a way of life that
consists of proper behavior in different
activities or functions or actions
proper ways that emphasize ritual and
family or filial piety not radical
individualism and that points to
virtuous action a little bit less as
character simply and more in terms of
again gentlemanly propriety and
refinement even a kind of mannered
formalism in activity that's important
for the following reason for him you
might wish to act correctly but what
actually is correct behavior also
depends on how others understand what
you're doing and how you see them and
that's one reason why observing custom
and ritual can be important for
displaying proper respect this is from
book a chapter to the master said if one
is courteous but does without ritual
then one dissipates one's energy if one
is cautious but does without ritual then
one becomes timid if one is bold but
does without ritual then one becomes
reckless if one is forthright but does
without ritual then one becomes rude and
it's the need for ritual to actually
bring about proper action whatever one's
intention because government politics
government is such an interest of ours
let me discuss Confucius's
views on this further Confucius is
sayings on this are largely about
officials in government and their
behavior how they should act what their
relations are central is trust and the
similarity between action in the family
and activity in government his remarks
are not really very much about
institutions or even about justice
directly but primarily about behavior an
action
let me read a few things to give you a
sense of what his views on this are Duke
ding asked how rulers should employ
ministers and how ministers should serve
rulers Master Kong replied rulers and
employing ministers do so in accordance
with ritual and ministers and serving
rulers do so in accordance with loyalty
Zi Zhong asked about government the
master said if there's enough food and
if there are enough weapons the people
will put their trust in it Zi Zhang said
suppose you definitely had no
alternative but to give up one of these
three food weapons trust which would you
relinquish first the master said I would
give up weapons Zi Zhang said suppose
you definitely had no alternative but to
give up one of the remaining two which
would you relinquish first the master
said I would give up food from of old
Death Comes to all men but a people will
not stand if it lacks trust and then
I'll read a couple more on government
dongdong being steward to the G family
asked about government the master said
give a lead to your officials pardon
minor errors and promote men of quality
and talent he said how does one
recognize man of quality and talents
so as to promote them he said the master
said promote those you do recognize for
will others neglect those you do not
recognize to decide how helpful that
answer is and one more
ji Kang Zi asked how the people might be
induced to be respectful and loyal so
they might be properly encouraged the
master said if you oversee them with
dignity they will be respectful if your
dutiful towards your parents and kind to
your children then they will be loyal if
you promote the good and instruct the
incompetent then they will be encouraged
let me now say something very briefly
about the the following question what
given all this could one say about about
Confucius and contemporary Chinese
politics and government during Mao's
reign as I said Confucius was condemned
as a reactionary but now the rulers
celebrate him as I said they call their
Institute's Confucian Institute's the
question is whether or not Confucius is
writings are a force for individual
freedom rights privacy and independence
he's certainly a force for virtue you
mainus learning trust and friendship and
in that sense justice Aristotle would be
against tyranny
Confucius favors a kind of gentleman
leanest Confucius also distinguishes
governments that follow the right way
from those that do not follow the right
way Confucius also argues in favor of
the importance of the proper alignment
of names and things the
rectification of names of calling
political and social things what they
actually are
one might say he opposes in advance some
of our political correctness moreover
although you may assist socially it's
also ultimately in one's own power to
try to seek it but as I said we do not
see in Confucius the openness of
individual desire and satisfaction and
there's a limit which comes from the
great importance he places on the kind
of given political and social roles so I
would say but anyone could disagree that
Confucius the actual Confucius of the
Analects is on the whole a healthy or
salutary force for good politics but not
simply healthy because you could not
honestly say that the current leaders
are expressing proper Confucian
qualities so I'll say a couple more
things and then we can then we can have
we can have some questions
Confucius took many characteristics
seriously and he wanted them for himself
and in many ways these self
understandings are seen as exemplary for
other people as well the master said the
failure to cultivate virtue the failure
to put it into practice the failure to
put into practice what I've learned
hearing what is right and being unable
to move towards it being unable to
change what's not good these are my
worries
the master said in making an effort
I am comparable with others but as to
myself being a gentleman in practice I
have never yet managed to achieve that
the master said at 15 I set my heart on
learning at 30 I was established at 40 I
had no perplexities at 50 I understood
the decrees of heaven at 60 my ear was
in accord and at 70 I followed what my
heart desired but did not transgress
what was right the master said do I for
my part really possess understanding no
I do not possess understanding but if
there is an ordinary person putting a
question to me although his mind seems
to be quite blank I hammer at both sides
of the question and go into it
thoroughly
Confucius also took music and poetry
very seriously and the beauty connected
to them and the proper behavior that
sometimes connected to them and this is
like Plato but he doesn't think through
her attempt even to think through
universal characteristics by which one
could specify beauty I'll conclude with
his humor or even his sarcasm and a
couple of my favorite sayings in
addition to the ones I've read G wen Zi
fought fought three times before acting
when the master heard of this he said
twice will be enough
and a couple of others the master said
if a man does not anticipate deception
and does not reckon on bad faith but on
the other hand is aware and good time
when they occur he is a man of quality
isn't he and then finally 2:17 the
master said you is one of the disciples
as nickname is you you shall I teach you
about understanding something when you
understand something to recognize that
you understand it but when you do not
understand something to recognize that
you do not understand it that is
understanding
and then actually this is the final one
now so I can't I can't I can't resist
this especially in this context the
master said it is not easy to find
anyone who studies for three years but
is not intent on a salary so that's
Confucius in a nutshell thank you
thank you doctor blitz we now have time
for a few questions please make your way
to the microphone if you have a question
aras artist Allah was the one that
discovered men's mind and reason and
understanding the world that way aren't
you giving Confucius too much credit by
comparing him to Aristotle because
Aristotle is unique in the known history
of the world I try to I try to lay out
some of the differences between
Aristotle and Confucius the grounds of
comparison come from you know the
relative similarity in time Confucius is
older and the listing of the virtues and
the listing of the human qualities and
the thinking through of those qualities
that's really the the substance of the
comparison but in a way it's precisely
the philosophical underpinnings that you
don't see in Confucius and the full
working out of the various dimensions
and possibilities of the virtues
happiness and so on so I think I'm
giving Aristotle his proper rank you'd
mentioned over here exit stage right or
something you had mentioned that during
Mao's time he tried to eliminate
references to Confucius of course there
was the famous little red book of Mao
during the Cultural Revolution in your
knowledge of of Confucius do you know
whether any of his particular sayings
were plagiarized my mouth no I don't
know concretely but I wouldn't be
surprised
you know Mao also in the condemnation of
Confucius had everyone read Confucius to
see all the things that were wrong which
was maybe not so wise
and and and the new group the new group
is Reiser about those matters I would
say but I would really have to look
carefully at the little red book and
other works of mod to answer that
question concretely so speaking of the
new regime and how they've more or less
capitulated to the cultural history of
Confucianism given the insights on how
they've managed to sort of round the
square peg there around stuff like for
example calling it like it is stuff like
that's not very common with Soviet style
totalitarian communist regimes you know
there is this element in Confucius where
you you act as you should in relation to
the role that you have Confucius is not
revolutionary it's not radical really in
in his thinking in even the way that
let's say Plato is so I think you can
work with elements and Confucius in a
useful way but in the long run if people
take Confucius seriously they will see
the difference between the government
they have and the virtues that are being
suggested by Confucius so there there's
a lot of material that you can work with
in sort of incorporating Confucius into
your your arguments and your propaganda
hi thank you for you speak your speech
today would you say that the current
regime has tried to capture Confucianism
the way that the left here in America is
as captured as liberal I even here can
see conservatives speak about the left
as if they deserve the title liberal and
I'm wondering if you could make that
comparison I mean for a while the
general kind of category for our regime
is indeed liberal democracy so it's not
it's it's not accurate right as you're
suggesting for liberalism and the truth
to be captured by the left and even the
left of this kind of left-right divide
which kind of became formal and in a way
in the in the 1820s or 1830s the liberal
element there was a pro-business
and pro Parliament element so yeah
there's something wrong about the way in
which we talk about our politics for
sure yes I think the goal of the current
regime and I think that's true of in a
way any thoughtful regime is to try to
have behind you as much as you can that
you think the people won't give up so
radical as you might be it may often be
the case that you want to show elements
of what you're doing is continuous with
what's been there in the past how
successful that will be I don't know I
mean that's that would be a prediction
that it would be that it would be hard
to make so we'll see
you mentioned weapons so I know
Confucius thought about it could you
share some sayings on his ideas about
war and conflict
so archery arteries of one of the things
that you're supposed to study Confucius
was not ultimately that interested in
war he's not really I think where you
look for strategy is there of course
other great works that that you look at
its secondary always to virtue you might
say Confucius is not against punishment
but punishment is secondary to virtue
also shouldn't be necessary so Confucius
is more in that direction and not so
much in the direction of war and
conflict harmony would come closer to
what he might desire and conflict would
no he's certainly not a pacifist and
himself and engaged in certain kind of
political activities he's not a pacifist
but war is not his favorite option war
there are a lot of wars then though and
you needed you needed to fight in order
to preserve to preserve yourself and to
preserve your dynasty so pacifism no but
war as something desirable not much
courage is one of the virtues but it's
not one that goes all that far by itself
either but certainly not pacifism
probably like many of us here in the
room I graduated from college in 69 and
Chairman Mao's little red book was kind
of everywhere even though I was under
relatively safe campus so to speak and I
wasn't reminded of that until one of
Obama's initial appointees declared that
mal and mother Teresa were her favorite
philosophers and I is there anyone
outside of people in Berkeley and
Harvard who think of mal as a
philosopher is he venerated in his
country are they trying to discredit him
I will leave mother Teresa out of it
yeah I would you know I would say a lot
of this has to do with the relative
power of China and the resurgence of
that kind of activity and that kind of
politics they're fewer direct Maoists
than there were in the late 60s early
70s but there's a still I think a
serious strain among certain people of a
kind of a kind of Maoism but how far
something like that will go it depends
very much on what happens I think in
China itself I don't come across even
the colleagues of whom I'm not that fond
dancing up and down to tell me how
wonderful Mao is but of course I would
not be the one in front of whom they'd
perform such a dance
good evening sir thank you so much for
coming to Hillsdale this evening for
your discussion in Steven mousers book
the bully of Asia
he draws attention to a comment from
Confucius that reads just as there are
not two suns in the sky so there cannot
be two Emperor's on earth and he ties it
into ancient Chinese history my question
for you is from as you understand him
does Confucian teaching endorsed the
ambitions of conquest by brute force as
done from the great unification to the
disputes with the West today well
Stephen Mosher will speak to you so you
can see what he says I would say no he
doesn't endorse conquest by brute force
because his goals are not really served
by brute force but his his picture of
the best government was what you can
consider a whole Empire over the
territory that he knew best didn't
really function that way when he was
alive and who knows whether it ever
really functioned that way but that was
the government that he liked best so
that there might be a single Empire over
the known territory could well be if
that needed to be brought about by force
one way or the other
perhaps but not something I think that
he would want to be kept in place by
force kept in place by fear but rather
by these other qualities he's discussing
Confucius would have been approximately
a contemporary of the prophet Daniel
from the Old Testament and Daniel would
have had known the history of the
Hebrews of course and he studied the
Chaldeans I just wonder whether you are
aware of any connection educationally
whether Confucius could have gotten his
ideas about virtue and and the you know
the principal underpinnings of him seem
to have a lot of parallels
with biblical history and I just wonder
if you could address that well I'm not
aware of any direct connection it would
be difficult because of the kind of
isolation of these places from each
other I mean their various arguments to
the effect that and which find it very
interesting that you have so many
movements in religion and and even
philosophy more or less around the same
time make making somewhat similar
statements but I doubt that there would
be any direct connection but you know
one one can never say never but I don't
none that I'm aware of and and and I
would doubt is given the the range of
things that Confucius knew of or didn't
know of given he traveled but the travel
is obviously limited so you would have
to find something that somehow came and
that he that he saw and I think that's
not all that likely a lot of his thought
of course resonates with things in the
past but some of it is novel as well so
that would be my view but those things
are always subject to two new new
discovery
thank you dr. blitz thank you
[Applause]